Intrepreneurship is about solving
problem,
about,
uh,
addressing the issues of the world
around yourself is not just making
money.
That's what I meant by entrepreneurship.
And entrepreneurship is something that
we carry with us as a human being.
We came in this planet,
uh,
to solve problems.
We solve problems all around us and we
continue to solve that problem.
And that's how we survived.
Uh,
we were in adverse circumstances when he
came to this planet,
but we will not frightened by that
adverse circumstances.
We took them back grip and one by one we
tried to solve them and we kept on a
solid with them.
As a result,
we came millions of years on this planet
and survived and successful.
So there's entrepreneurship.
I any,
any human capability used for solving
problem for mankind,
for the planet.
Uh,
I would consider this an intervention.
Yeah.